[MUSIC PLAYING]
YASMIN GREEN: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining this
"Authors" at this lunch time.
I am Yasmin Green.
I run research and
development for a group
called Jigsaw, which is
Alphabet's technology incubator
looking at geopolitics.
And I am delighted
to welcome Wendy
Sachs to talk to us today.
We're related.
We've got to figure out the
exact way to describe it,
but Wendy's the sister of
my husband's cousin's wife.
There should be a short
term, shorthand for that.
And so, if you guys
are anything like me,
you feel some anxiety when you
think about the evolving nature
of work.
And automation and
globalization seem
like they're trends
that are making
more bleak the prospects of us
all being gainfully employed
in the future.
And job security seems like
a kind of romantic notion
from a past era.
And yet we still all
want, yearn for work
that's nourishing and
stimulating and flexible
and that brings us joy as
well as pays the bills.
And then sometimes we fantasize
about charting a new path.
But we're not even
sure where we'd
start when it comes to that.
So wouldn't we love
the advice of somebody
who has experience with every
possible permutation of work,
life, family and has reinvented
themselves and captured
their insights in a book
that will help empower us
and help us all thrive?
And that is Wendy Sachs.
That's the brilliance of Wendy.
And Wendy has a very diverse and
accomplished career as an Emmy
award-winning producer of TV
news on "Dateline," BBC, CNN,
Fox, and NBC, is a
critically acclaimed author
and journalist, and has an
eclectic career in politics
and PR, including
holding the title of--
I'm not going to get
this right-- now, wait,
she can correct me,
Capitol Hill chief--
WENDY SACHS: [INAUDIBLE]
YASMIN GREEN: Oh,
press secretary,
Capital Hill press
secretary, editor in chief,
and also which I didn't
get the 411 from her about,
but also representative of
Barney the purple dinosaur.
So anyway, without
further ado, it's
a great joy to welcome Wendy
to share her insights with us
today.
[APPLAUSE]
That's for you.
WENDY SACHS: Thanks so much.
Thank you for that
warm introduction.
I am honored to be
related to Yas, even
by some sort of cousin
marriage relationship.
Talking about
fearless, I think I
don't know anyone who is
more fearless and bad ass
than this woman who's doing
incredible work here at Google.
So I'd say that I've
pivoted so much in my career
that I'm practically
pirouetting.
And not all of my pivots
have been intentional.
I've been fired.
I've lost my job
a couple of times.
And you know, because
everything today has an origin
story, every brand, everything.
My origin story of
"Fearless and Free"
begins when I lost my
job in August of 2014.
And I was working at
a advertising agency
and it's sort of a
minitragedy to lose
your job in advertising.
It happens all the time.
And they gave me
some notice, and I
knew I was going to be let go,
because they couldn't afford me
anymore apparently.
And I started interviewing
all around New York City.
I started going to all of
these what I would call
the bright and shiny start ups.
I'm sure you work with many
of them here in New York.
And I was going around
looking for a job.
My industry, media, had
been completely disrupted
by digital.
And I started really panicking
because at this point,
I'm over 40.
And I'm in an industry
that is overrun by people,
now, about 20 years
younger than me.
And I thought if I
don't get a job soon,
I'm not going to be relevant.
And of course, as we all
know, relevance is everything.
So I was interviewing at
one shop, and I went in,
and of course it was a bearded
millennial in that flannel,
like the total cliche,
sitting across from me.
And I take out, start
taking out my resume, which
is sort of lengthy at
this point, and my bio.
And I hand it to him.
Right away I knew that
there was trouble.
He said we don't take
paper resumes around here.
We only want digital copies.
And I was like, feeling
embarrassed and shamed,
and that clearly I was way
too old for this company.
I shoved my paper
back in my bag.
And he opens up his MacBook and
he's looking over my resume.
And he sees that I had
worked on Capitol Hill.
I was a press
secretary a while ago.
But I still kept
it on my resume,
because it was a position that
I always felt very proud of.
Up until this point, it
had given me some gravitas
and some credibility.
And what I like to say is that
Capitol Hill was the Google
of the Gen X generation.
It opened doors for us.
It opened big careers
for many people.
We all-- many people
I know started
there went on to big careers.
But here, the man looking at
me sort of scoffed and said,
around here we have good
relationships with the media.
I wouldn't want you hanging up
on any reporters or anything.
And completely startled
by this, I said,
you know, jokingly,
well, I'm not
a character in "Veep"
or "The House of Cards."
I wasn't screaming at reporters.
I was begging them to cover
my member of Congress.
He was a freshman member
from a crowded district
in South Florida.
He didn't even laugh
at any of this.
So after I started walking
through the office,
holding on to my paper resume,
and grabbing my coconut water
and kale chips as I walked
out, feeling sort of depressed.
I was walking down Fifth
Avenue, and I thought to myself.
Something's gotta change.
Obviously, I have
done what I think
has been very interesting
jobs in my career.
I'm clearly qualified
for these positions.
What am I doing wrong?
And I had this sort of epiphany.
And I started looking
towards Silicon Valley.
I was sort of always
obsessed with the tech world,
the way that so many of us are.
And because that whole start
up spirit in tech world,
in Silicon Valley's basically
directing everything
we do today, as you know
better than anyone--
from how we shop, to
how we get our news
and out entertainment,
how we target ISIS--
everything we do is
coming from the start
up space, Silicon
Valley, the tech world.
So one of the themes and one
of the sort of characteristics
that sort of struck
me at this time,
it was because I'd seen
this "New York Magazine"
article about that whole
failure fetish coming out
of Silicon Valley.
And I thought, well,
I understand failure.
I've failed a few times.
But what is it about
that whole failure
idea, that embracing of
failure that's so part
of the DNA of the tech world?
And why is it a badge
of honor for these boys
in the hoodies who launch
companies that blow up--
they're not going and climbing
into a hole and disappearing.
No, I mean, from
what I'm reading,
they're getting rehired.
Or they're just pivoting
on their business, right?
That the venture
capitalists are investing
in the people and the talent
behind the business, not
necessarily the business idea.
And of course, there's dozens
of examples to point to.
So I just loved that idea.
And I thought, what if women
did that in their own careers?
What if women sort
of owned that concept
that we don't need to feel
ashamed if we lose a job,
as so many people do today?
What if we really
invested in ourselves
and leaned into our own
skills, and realized
we just need to pivot?
We need to iterate.
And what if we were OK
with that idea of failure?
So as I started digging into
this concept of failure,
of course, a cousin, the happy
cousin to failure is success.
And as Albert Einstein-- so many
people have these great quotes
around failure--
he says, failure is
the pathway to success,
something like that.
I'm paraphrasing that.
But that's that idea.
So I started looking
at confidence, right?
So confidence is the foundation
to building anything,
to taking risks.
And it's all about
the risk taking.
And of course, I'm
sure you're all
familiar with all the
studies that show men are
more willing to take
risks than women.
We know men start more
companies, more start
ups than women.
They certainly get the
financing, the venture capital
backing that women don't get.
So why is that?
So as I started
looking into some
of the research
around confidence,
I was looking at Claire
Shipman and Katty Kay.
I don't know if anyone here
is familiar with their book,
"The Confidence Code,"
which sort of became
my Bible as I was doing my
own research on confidence.
And they found that there's
this genetic connection
with confidence.
That there's actually--
there's a genetic component,
sort of like who gets
blue eyes or curly hair.
And they did their
own DNA testing
and they found very
disappointingly
that neither one of them
carried that genetic trait
to actually create confidence.
And of course this was
incredibly disheartening
to them, because you want to
think that you are genetically
enabled to be confident.
But what they also found, which
of course is very empowering,
is that we can build confidence.
Confidence is a muscle,
like resilience is a muscle
that Sheryl Sandberg, of course,
is recently talking about.
Confidence is also a muscle.
And the fastest way to become
confident is to take risks.
And women just generally
are more risk averse.
And we're taught
this at an early age.
We don't like to fail.
We don't like to
get things wrong.
take as many chances.
And it starts really early on.
So the more studies that I
was uncovering, and looking
at the writings of Carol Dweck,
who's a well known professor,
and she wrote a book
called "Mindset,"
she writes about that this
starts at a very early age.
With that whole idea
of a growth mindset
versus a fixed mindset--
the idea that we sort of
only know what we know
is that fixed mindset.
That you are good at math
and that is what you know,
but you would not be
good at, perhaps, art.
Versus that whole idea
of a growth mindset
that you can develop your
skills, and you can turn into--
you can sort of evolve and
you can iterate as you go.
Well, this is really
important, not just
in the parenting space, as
it became recently adopted.
Because there's
that whole concept
that we're not supposed
to tell our daughters that
they're good at math.
Because maybe in fifth
grade they're good at math,
but by ninth grade
when math gets hard,
and they're not doing
so well, they now
take it personally
and think, I guess
I'm just not so good at math.
We're supposed to
praise the journey.
But this is also very
true to ourselves.
If we can't accept
the idea that we
can continue to evolve and grow,
well, we're going to get stuck.
So these things were
very interesting to me.
This whole the
risk taking versus
growth mindset
versus fixed mindset
and how we think about
ourselves and how--
our ability and our willingness
to really take risks.
But along with this whole
confidence and internalization
of how we're feeling,
it's also about how
we present to the world.
And so as I was
writing this book--
the book is not a
memoir, but very much
a personal journey for
me as I was exploring
my own sort of what
was happening out there
in the workforce and
what I needed to change.
And it was also the election.
And so, during the
election, of course,
we saw how women are perceived.
Of course, the person carrying
the mantle for all of us
was Hillary Clinton.
And we saw that the way that
she was perceived to the voters,
to the population, to the
media was that she came across
as either too shrill,
too inauthentic,
she wasn't warm enough.
She was judged to a
different standard.
And there was this famous
Jimmy Kimmel sketch
that I don't know
if any of you saw,
but I read about in the book.
And in this one sketch,
he sort of-- this
is like, what they call
the mansplaining sketch.
And so Hillary's
standing behind a podium.
And she's pretending that
she's giving her stump speech.
And she starts out
a little bit loud.
And he's, oh, keep it down.
Keep it down.
The voice-- the voice,
it's a little too shrill,
a little too loud.
She drops it down.
You gotta raise your voice.
You're sounding like
a mouse up there.
And she begins again.
And he's like, you
don't look right.
You gotta smile more.
You gotta smile.
So she starts smiling.
You look like a Lakers girl.
What's with the smile?
You know, whatever she did.
It went on and on.
And then he's like, you know,
I can't put my finger on it.
I'm not sure what is it?
What is it about you
that's just not right?
I know.
You're not a man.
And that, of course, was
the ultimate poking fun
at exactly what was
happening and exactly how she
was being perceived.
And that, of course,
is the double bind.
And I'm sure-- is everyone
here familiar with that?
Double bind-- and the
women in leadership?
So that double bind is
the ultimate conundrum
for women in leadership.
And that is, that
when women present
with more masculine
characteristics--
that they are direct or
they have a loud voice
or they come off very strong,
they're not well liked.
People see them as abrasive,
or they're bitches.
They're not well liked.
But when women present with
their more feminine qualities,
that they are nurturing and
seem to be warm, engaging,
maybe their voice
isn't so loud, they're
not thought to be
strong leaders.
So that's the conundrum, right?
That is the double bind.
And of course, we saw that
play out during the campaign,
not to say that
Hillary Clinton didn't
have other issues going on,
but that was a big part of it.
So all of this is
happening as I'm
writing the book, the campaign,
I'm watching what's happening.
And by the way, just a compare
and contrast, when you saw--
and this was not just a
Democrat-Republican thing.
You see Bernie Sanders,
who's pounding the podium,
and finger thrusting, and he's
messy, and he's disheveled,
and he's loud, and he's angry.
People love that.
Right?
People love that about Bernie.
There was no you're too loud.
You're too obnoxious.
Your hair's a mess.
Fix your tie.
You know, stop with the finger.
No!
That was manly.
It was alpha.
It was legitimate.
It was authentic.
And people loved it.
Women loved it.
So that's really, really-- that
was very fascinating to me.
And I think, at
some level, I also
had this sort of personal
association with all of this.
Not that I'm anywhere near
Hillary Clinton's level,
or will be.
But I had been viewed
in the workforce,
at one particular job,
as being too abrasive.
I was told this in
one of my job reviews,
that I came across as a little
bit too abrasive, too tough.
What I thought was being
direct, other people
viewed and perceived as being--
and the word that's commonly
associated with women--
is abrasive.
And I was horrified.
I felt so--
I don't want to say ashamed,
but I felt so hurt, actually.
I mean, I didn't want
people not to like me,
because everyone
wants to be liked.
And by the way, likability
in the work force
goes a really long way.
And so I didn't know what
to do about all of this.
And so, at the same time
that this was all happening
and I was feeling very
sad about not being liked,
I wound up actually
getting a new job.
And I went to the advertising
agency I'd mentioned before.
And I started
saying sorry a lot.
I was just dropping in
sorry, sorry, sorry,
where do I hang this report?
Sorry, opening the door when
I go into a room, sorry.
And I was adopting this
sorry because there
was another colleague
of mine, who, granted--
she was like, blonde
and petite and dimpled,
and very sweet-- she
would always say sorry.
And no one ever thought
that she was a bitch
or that she was too
direct, or that she
came across as abrasive.
So I thought, I'm going to
use this whole sorry thing.
And it worked like a charm.
I'm telling you, I was with
the toughest creative guys
who are feeling all bold
and all that going on.
But no one thought I was being
too direct, because I wasn't.
I had dialed it back.
And so interestingly,
at this time
at the agency where
I was working,
there was a Pantene
commercial that came out.
And I don't know
if you remember,
it was a few years ago.
And it got a lot of recognition.
And it was a campaign
where they were showing--
it was for Pantene--
and they were showing all
these different circumstances
of women apologizing.
So in one scene, you
see a woman on a subway.
And a man sits next to her,
his legs are spread open.
And she's doing this,
like, and she says, sorry.
And in another scene,
you see a kitchen.
And the woman is
handing over a child,
which looks like it's either
to her husband or partner
or whoever.
As she hands the baby
over, she says, sorry.
Another instance, a woman in
an office is opening up a door.
There's men sitting at the
table, and she says, sorry.
And so it was a whole
slew of sorries.
And basically, they were
making fun of the fact
that women are
apologizing all the time.
So now I'm feeling
sorry for saying sorry.
And I quickly dropped my sorry.
And it was at the
ad agency where
I was working that they
actually produced the ad.
So it was this like,
total sort of awakening
of what's going on.
And during this time
also, I'm sure you also
heard of all of the
other shrinker words
that people talk about.
The justs and the actuallys,
and the am I making sense,
and all the language that
really diminishes our power.
And does anyone know
Tammy Reese in this room?
So Tammy Reese actually
created a gmail plug
in that was going to be like
the spell check for sorry.
And it got a lot of attention.
I see some heads saying yes.
It got a lot of attention.
And I interviewed
her for the book.
And she talks about the
fact that it wasn't supposed
to change the way that
we communicate entirely,
like saying, you know, like,
shame on you for saying just.
Because we think
that's sort of breezy.
Sometimes you want to
say just in a sentence.
But her feeling was she
wanted to make women
aware of the language
that they were using
and how we are
presenting to the world.
Because it is so incredibly
important how we present.
And so some of the
suggestions that, when
I started asking
some experts, like,
OK, we use these justs
and the actuallys
because we don't want to be
seen as abrasive and too direct,
so we try to come across
as a little softer.
The suggestions are
opening your email warm,
ending your email warm.
In the middle, scrub any justs,
actuallys, am I making sense.
And that's the smartest
approach to do.
And you can do that
in person, too,
when you walk into a meeting.
You can start with some
small talk about the weather
or whatever.
But then be direct, smile,
end warm, you're done.
But there are no apologizing.
And so I thought that was really
also very, very interesting.
What is it that women are
doing that is inadvertently
affecting our power, diminishing
our strength to the world?
So another thing that
I also looked at when,
again, looking toward Silicon
Valley for all of my answers,
I looked at the concept of
engineering serendipity.
Do you all know what that is?
I feel like this is a
group that-- engineering
serendipity-- so many of
us think of serendipity
as a happy accident.
Or it's just good
fortune, somehow
like, great things
just happened.
But actually, there is
strategy behind serendipity.
We can make that magic happen.
And a few years ago
at South by Southwest,
it actually became sort of
a theme of the conference.
There was a bunch of sessions
with creative agencies and tech
companies all talking
about this concept
of engineering serendipity.
We can create these
amazing collisions
of creativity and
innovation, which to me was
like incredibly eye opening.
Oh, we can actually make
these things happen for us.
So the one man in my
book is a guy named Mike,
and he's the only
dude in the book.
And I call him the
King of Serendipity.
Because while we have worked
together several times,
so I benefited from his
own kingdom of serendipity
because he's hired
me a few times,
he was always able to sort of
maneuver between a whole bunch
of different things.
He was working for Larry Ellison
and running some sort of start
up company.
He also was writing screenplays.
He's also producing
digital series.
He started out as a
TV news journalist.
So he, somehow, was able to
zigzag between industries,
make money, have three
children, and to me,
like, sort of live the dream.
And I looked at him thinking,
how is he doing that?
Well, part of it, I realized,
is that he is a guy.
So when he would invite me to go
to networking events, he'd say,
hey, you should
come out for drinks.
I'm meeting with
this movie producer.
He's in from LFA and we're
talking about this script
that I just wrote.
I would say I gotta
catch the train.
I gotta get home.
But somehow, he was able to
keep building his network,
keep expanding his
boundaries, and keep creating
this magic for himself.
So when I was looking into this
whole concept of engineering
serendipity, I interviewed Mike.
And I said, what is it?
How did you do this?
He actually had a
formula for serendipity.
I couldn't believe it.
He had a mathematical
equation that I'm not
going to be able to
remember right now.
It's in my book.
But it's about visibility,
sort of dividing
by what you've done in the
past, and where you're located.
And it was like a whole formula
to creating this perfect magic
for himself.
But what he was
doing was something
that's actually been studied
for many, many years.
And it's about this idea that
you're opening boundaries.
And as you're
expanding your network,
you're creating
opportunities for yourself.
But you're also being seen.
You're also being visible.
You're putting in the work.
So it's not just magically
appearing for you.
You've actually
done your homework.
You've started a project.
You've done some research.
You've created your side gig.
So you're doing
something on the side.
So now you're actually
sort of getting there.
You're making, you're taking
the steps to get there.
And now you're putting
yourself in a place
whether it's a networking
event or a conference
or some sort of
meet up where you're
meeting with the right people.
And then, the key
to all of it, is
that you're seizing
on the opportunity,
that you're ready for it.
You now have your
eyes wide open,
and you can see the opportunity,
and you seize the moment.
You're not held back by fear.
You're not held back by
feeling not confident.
So I thought that was
really, really fascinating.
And by the way, as I was
exploring serendipity,
I saw that it happens
here at Google,
which you all must know about.
I mean this whole innovation
time off, the 20%?
I don't know.
Does anyone actually do that?
They do?
OK, that is brilliant
and revolutionary.
And that's another time where
your company is saying to you,
go explore.
Go innovate.
Go be creative.
Go have the headspace
to go work on something.
Because we know that
when you have the time
and that sort of
mental space to do it,
great things are
going to happen.
And that is really,
really similar
to this whole notion
of serendipity.
And what has held a
lot of women back,
and I was actually
interviewing a guy who's
writing an entire
book on serendipity,
is that he said that
women don't generally
have the time to noodle.
We don't have the time to be
creative when we're working
a full-time job and
we have a family,
and you're rushing to get
home, pick up your child from
daycare, or make a train--
you just don't have
that time built in.
Whereas men just sort of
either create the time,
aren't racing to
get to the train
or relieve the
babysitter from daycare
or their nanny in the same way.
And they have more time.
So I do think that
there's definitely
sort of a gender divide, a bit
of a gender gap in this area.
Because we tend to
not have the time,
or we're not taking
it upon ourselves
to be able to engineer
this moment for ourselves,
this serendipity.
The other issue that, of
course, I kept exploring,
which is part and parcel to
everything in the tech world
today, is networking.
Right, so it's all
about networking.
Everything we do
today is networking.
That is the sort of
foundation of how we connect,
and it's all about the networks.
But one of the things
that women haven't really
had until very recently are
really strong female networks.
And I will tell
you, and I'm older
than maybe a lot of you
sitting here in the room,
but when I was coming
up through the ranks
and I worked in media, I
had a lot of female bosses.
But I never felt as if--
I didn't feel like it was
an all out catfight, where
we were like crawling
over each other,
trying to get to the top.
But I didn't feel like any of
my bosses or any of the women
who I worked with were
trying to lift me with them.
I didn't feel like
they were raising me.
I did feel like
there was a smaller
piece of the pie at the top.
They wanted to hold onto it.
So they didn't pull me
along in the process.
But I have really seen a huge
change in the past few years--
are the amount of
female networks
out there in all
different industries.
Of course, you probably know
about the tech industry.
And there's so many
here in New York,
and there's so
many in different--
from Nashville to
Austin to San Francisco.
But I'm talking about a whole
bunch of different industries.
I have a friend
who is actually--
she's an interior designer.
She was out in, I think Sun
Valley a few weekends ago,
with her female
network of designers.
And of course, they're
using technology.
They're using the WhatsApp
chats and Facebook
and different groups to connect
and to support each other.
This just didn't
exist in the same way.
So as I was really digging into
female networks, of course,
I found one that maybe some of
you know about, Tech LadyMafia?
Tech LadyMafia?
So Aminatou Sow created Tech
LadyMafia with a friend.
And the whole idea
around this network,
not just let's connect
and support each other,
but they actually have
done something really,
really, I think, unique
and really empowering
for women in that
they've codified
this whole concept of asking
for something and offering.
So when you show up to a
meet up for Tech LadyMafia,
it's implied that you might
need something from someone,
and you're also willing to give.
Because here's the thing.
We women do not like
to ask for help.
We don't like to say, hey, can
you hook me up with someone?
Hey, can you help me.
I'm trying to design a website.
I really don't know
what I'm doing.
We don't really like
to ask for help.
We tend to sort of take
it out on ourselves.
But they have actually
codified this whole concept
of asking and offering, which
is really amazing to me.
So that was one of the
networks that I found.
But, again, it's just sort
of this whole sisterhood
that I feel like we're really
feeling across the country
right now, particularly,
even, after the election.
As a side note, I'm working
on a project following
women who are running for
office for the first time.
And some of these
candidates have
created their own political
networks of other women.
Which again, completely
new and revolutionary,
which is really going to change
the whole landscape for women
out there.
So to create our
serendipity, we also
have to have a strong network.
We need to be able
to lean into women.
We also need to be able
to grow our networks,
because, of course, there's
all these studies that show you
only know who you know, right?
So you're not going to
really get jobs or find
other opportunities only by
the network of people you know.
You need to keep
expanding your boundaries.
So I thought this was
pretty fascinating, too.
And today, as you all
know, in the tech space,
it's art meets technology.
Retail meets technology.
Entertainment meets technology.
There's all these
intersections today.
And the more that we
push out and meet people
who we don't yet know
and experience industries
we aren't familiar with,
the more opportunity
we have for ourselves.
And the last theme that I
was really sort of into,
because it's so obvious,
is branding, right?
How do we talk about ourselves?
How do we share who we are?
Again, this is a concept
that a lot of women
can be very squeamish about.
We don't like to
brag about ourselves.
We don't like to boast
about what we've done.
And this really
came to light when
I was speaking in Washington,
DC a few weeks ago to a group
of 50 female attorneys.
All of them unemployed--
because they'd all either
worked at the White
House for Obama
or for the Justice
Department under Obama.
So we had 50 Democratic
women, female attorneys,
all looking for a job.
And they said, you
know, it was in November
when Hillary lost the election.
They knew they were going
to need to find a new job.
And they started
rewriting their resumes.
And they said, we work
with all of these men.
And you would have thought, by
looking at these guys' resumes,
that they were running
the Justice Department.
They basically-- everything that
happened, they owned, they did.
Where the women really
thought, yeah, well, I
was at that meeting.
I was on that team.
You know, I can't
really say I did that.
But the guys, they were like,
running the West Wing, also.
So you know, it's such an
interesting gender divide
in how we own what
it is that we do
and how we share with the
world what it is that we do.
But the only way
for people to know
is that visibility again, right?
Everything is online.
Everything is
through social media.
Everything is about networking.
If we don't tell people
what it is that we do well,
they're not going to
know what we do well.
And so particularly, when
you're looking for a job,
or you're looking to pivot,
or you're looking to explore,
you're keeping your eyes open--
people need to know what
it is that you do well.
As the kids call it today,
what's your super power?
But surely you need to sort
of own your own narrative,
and what it is
that you do, and be
able to share that
with the world
and not feel so
squeamish about it.
You know, it has been sort of
thought to be impolite to brag,
but I would like to
change that whole notion.
That branding yourself is
not necessarily bragging,
it's about letting people
know what it is in the world
that we do.
So I would love to open
this up to questions,
if anyone has questions.
It's always more fun
to take questions.
Question?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
You've obviously
experienced being a working
woman, being single,
and married, having kids.
And some of your preferences
now are to life with a family.
And I, having a
kid, look back at--
I especially think I'm more--
I feel bolder and more confident
and more willing to take risks,
more willing to do
everything [INAUDIBLE],,
everything actually,
after having a child.
Because that was
positive, even though it
presented its own strain.
But I also look back
at my three year self,
and I'm like, wow, what
a squandered opportunity
to do more.
WENDY SACHS: That's
a great point.
AUDIENCE: So I guess some
of the people in this room
don't-- haven't yet gotten
to the point of having
your family.
And I'm wondering what
you'd urge those of us who
do and don't yet have some
of those other [INAUDIBLE]
and other commitments.
WENDY SACHS: I think
that's a great point.
And I would say use that free
time before you have children
to your fullest.
Explore everything that you can.
This is the time to create--
seize those opportunities,
and do everything
that it is that you want
to do, from also, even,
just traveling, seeing the
world and having experiences.
Because certainly in the early
years, when Zeba is young,
it's hard.
It's hard.
My kids are teenagers now.
And it's easier to have
that, also, mental space.
So I would not have
been able to write
this book a few years ago.
I think that we
also need that head
space to be able to explore and
to noodle and to get creative.
I also think that it's really
important for all of us
at any stage in your life
to really get comfortable
in the uncomfortable.
You know, that's a Navy SEALs
expression for obvious reasons.
And I am sure it's
been adopted by others.
But I really buy that belief.
Because that gives us all
the opportunity to get
used to feeling a
little uncomfortable.
And that's where the greatest--
that's where all the amazing
things that we're going to do
are going to come from.
That's where we're going to
be able to grow the most--
in taking jobs that
make us nervous, right?
Like, when we get
too complacent,
we're not bringing our A game.
And also, what's risky
for one person is not
risky for someone else.
So it's figuring out what
that risk is for you.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Can you
speak a bit more
to the concept of
pivoting and re-launching?
So how in your career
have you faced the need
to pivot from perhaps
one particular field
to a completely different one?
Or could you just talk a bit
more about how that plays out?
WENDY SACHS: Sure.
I would say that the
through line to my career
has been storytelling.
But that's before it was even
called storytelling, right?
It was called reporting.
It was called journalism.
It's called writing.
Now it's all storytelling.
I did-- I really
wanted to move into--
I wanted to get some
tech experience.
Although I'm not an engineer,
so not that kind of experience.
I've never coded before.
But I wanted to work
for a tech company.
So I had started on the Hill.
So I started in politics.
And then I moved to New
York, and I worked in TV.
I worked at
"Dateline NBC and Fox
and then Larry
Ellison was starting
this new internet
computer company.
And I got a job to be
his media director.
The company really blew up.
But it was my first experience
going to CS back in the day,
before CS became so wild.
And so I did that.
And then I actually
wrote another book
on work-life balance called
How She Really Does It.
And that actually
led me into going
into what we would call the
dark side, for journalists.
But I went into PR.
And I was doing the other side
of it all, which I actually
had an okay time with.
Now, of course, that's
called branded content,
everything that I was doing.
So the vernacular
keeps changing.
So I would say that there's
a bunch of different things
to mention with pivoting.
For people who are
going and doing
a full 180, like I want
to become a dentist now,
obviously that would be
incredibly different.
It would require me to
go to dental school.
But a lot of things, when people
say that they're pivoting,
at least what I've
found, they're
things that are almost
companions to things
that they're doing.
So they're not completely
removed from their skill sets.
So my whole advice is about
really leaning into your skills
and just figuring out the new
ones that you have to learn.
And as you know
better than anyone,
you can do this stuff online.
There's a lot of
ways to take classes.
To have that whole
side gig that everyone
seems to feel very
romantic about these days,
but having that sort of
side project that you
start noodling with to see
is there viability here?
Am I any good at this?
Can I make money if
I need to make money?
What can I really do?
And what I've also found is
just changing the language
of how we talk about ourselves.
I will tell you I have
scrubbed my LinkedIn profile,
in the past 10 years,
probably 35 times,
because I keep seeing
how job descriptions are
being posted now.
The language being used is so
different than the language
I was using.
So now everything that
I've done in my past
seems to be storytelling
and marketing.
I would never have called myself
a marketing person before.
But yet that's what
branded content is.
And so the world
just keeps changing.
So it's about also not
feeling like a fraud
for calling yourself--
putting that label on, when
you feel like that label
isn't exactly what you
went to school for,
but that's what
they're calling it now.
And yes, your skills apply.
So I'm not saying lie
and be a fraud at all.
But I'm saying that we
have to be a little bit
more open minded and realize
that to stay relevant,
you need to really see
where trends are going,
and see how you fit in there.
Or, if you want to
do a total relaunch,
figure out what you need to know
and learn to completely shift
gears, which could be
incredibly different than what
you know right now.
AUDIENCE: Hey there, so I was
actually at the confidence girl
code, whatever it's called,
conference that they hosted,
Katty, Shipman and whatnot,
in Baltimore a few months ago.
I was a panelist
on the STEM panel.
And so I took my
daughter, and we attended
the whole conference, actually.
And a summary of some
of the messages I heard
was, obviously, be
confident, stand up
straight, give a firm
handshake, look them in the eye.
But be authentic, be yourself.
And it was like this
tug of war of advice
that I felt like was kind of
contradictory in the message.
Because at the end
of the day, we're
telling women to sort
of reshape themselves,
to be more acceptable
in the male environment.
And one of the
things that I really
liked about Google
and Silicon Valley,
is that this concept
of, you don't
have to wear a suit
to be taken seriously.
And so the point
is that you don't
have to look a certain way--
as a man-- or sound
a certain way,
or even be particularly
social-- socially acceptable--
to be taken seriously.
And what really mattered
was that you were smart,
you had great ideas, and
you got the thing done.
So I guess my-- this is
probably more a comment,
to see what your
response might be.
But my hope is that
we can get to a place
where we can stop telling women
to change themselves, and get
to a place where--
just like the culture
we have built here--
you can be whatever you
need to be as a person,
and you'll still be accepted
because the work you produce
is excellent.
So I guess I'm kind of tired of
hearing all the advice around--
WENDY SACHS: That
we need to change.
AUDIENCE: --do this, do that.
And I did all those things.
And so when I sit
on panels, now,
what I say to the
young woman thinking
about careers in tech is, I'm
going to be honest with you.
You can stand up as straight
as you can stand up.
You can give firm
handshakes until you
make their knuckles bleed.
You can be the smartest
person in the room.
But you're always going
to be disadvantaged
because you're a woman.
And there's literally nothing
you can do to change that.
And so--
WENDY SACHS: I
think you're making
all very important
points that I think
we can all really appreciate.
And one of the things--
when I was talking
about even writing
about Hillary Clinton
in the book, and the way
she was perceived,
and her shrill tone.
And she's not warm, she's not
authentic, she's too smiley,
she's whatever it may be.
No one likes the way she
looks in her pantsuit,
she needs to lose weight,
all of that kind of stuff.
You're absolutely right.
And one of the women
who I quote in the book,
she talks about the fact that
we need to re-hear the way women
speak.
She actually makes this
comparison to pre-Title IX
and sports in women, that the
way that women in sports were
perceived 20 years ago, I
would argue still a bit today--
that they're not given
the same validity.
They're certainly not
given the same money.
We see that with
the US soccer team,
with the women's soccer,
that they make less then men,
yet they win way more
than the guys do.
But even that whole
idea that anyone
should tune in and watch women
play soccer-- that has changed.
Right?
I would say that people
still aren't really
watching the women
NBA league the way
that they watch the
men because people
say it's not as exciting.
And they don't have
the same kind of money.
But the notion is that we
as a country, as a people,
need to re-hear the
way that women speak.
So if a woman is
sounding a little--
her voice is going to
be higher than most men,
because that's the
way women are built.
To not discredit that,
and not think that that
is too harsh, or too
bitchy, or too annoying,
that we all must adapt to that.
So I do think
that, and maybe I'm
being a little
Pollyanna here, but I
think as more women
move up the ranks,
and as we lift more women, as
the sisterhood keeps bringing
women up with them,
and as I'm seeing
and as I feel very
strongly about, that things
will start changing.
We'll see more
females in technology.
We'll see more women
in leadership position,
we'll see more
women in Congress.
And we will adapt
and accept the way
they look, the way they sound,
the way that they communicate.
And that is when things
will start changing.
But even women don't like
the way that women present.
We really saw that play
out in the election.
It was really shocking
to so many of us,
when we looked at
the numbers, and we
looked at what was coming back.
Women just didn't
even like women.
And that's another big issue
of what needs to change.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
what I'd like to see
is more books around how to
be a person that can just
accept women the way they are.
I heard the advice around,
don't say I'm sorry so much.
I've heard it a lot.
And I really tried,
myself, to not
do it, until I reached a
point where I was like,
you know what?
Maybe we have it right.
To say you're sorry
is a good thing.
It's like you're being kind,
and empathetic, compassionate,
considerate.
Maybe the advice should
be to the assholes who
treat people who say I'm sorry
badly to not do that as opposed
to the other way around.
WENDY SACHS: Well, I
think, being authentic,
there's nothing wrong
with being authentic.
I think that when we are
authentic, that is actually--
the people who come across the
most authentic are the ones who
get jobs, are well liked.
And there's tons of
studies on all of that.
But when we are faking it,
people can size that up in it
millisecond.
I mean we see
facial expressions,
and we're sort of brilliant
at seeing inauthenticity.
So keep being you.
AUDIENCE: In your research,
did you hear any murmurings
or indications that perhaps
men are learning and listening
from how women usually approach
things, opening [INAUDIBLE],,
getting to the point,
closing warmly.
I don't think it's just
what can we learn from men,
and be better at.
It's what are women doing right
that men can also learn from?
WENDY SACHS: Well,
I mean, there are
a lot of studies that show that
the nurturing skills that women
have are incredibly
effective in leadership.
And we also know
that when women are
at the top in organizations,
when they have more management
roles, when they are in C-Suite
roles, businesses do better.
Study after study after
study proves that diversity
is good for the bottom line.
I didn't really see that the
guys are looking to women
to sort of soften up or
to be more collaborative
or to do the things
that women do so well.
I think that to the other--
I don't know your name, but--
to Katty's point, that
embracing who we are as women,
is really important
and really essential.
And I agree.
We don't need to change.
We need to be aware
of how we present,
because the truth is,
the rest of the world
hasn't caught up to us yet.
So I think it starts
with an awareness,
even back to Tammy
Reese's gmail plug.
And she's not saying, never say
just or actually or I'm sorry,
it's more of an awareness
of how we're communicating.
But I do think that
women should be leaning
into all of the skills
that we do so well, which
is we're great collaborators.
Right?
So even going back to that
whole idea about networking,
I've spoken to many
rooms, and I'll
say to women, who
likes to network here?
I mean, I can ask you all.
Who likes to network?
Anyone like to network?
No one?
So OK, well, you like
to-- well, you're really
confident and authentic
and good for you,
but so many women
don't like to network.
We feel that it makes us
feel a little uncomfortable.
We're asking for something,
and transactional,
and it feels very cold.
Guys have been doing it forever.
They go in, they say what
they need, they're out,
they get a beer, you know,
they go play golf, done.
Women don't like to do that.
But what we're
really, really good at
is building relationships.
And we're really good at
creating relationships
that last a long time.
We need to play the long game.
So I would argue,
that women, we need
to sort of rethink networking.
Think of it more--
even relabeling that.
We're connecting.
We're showing up and we are
connecting, because women
do that really, really well.
We bond very quickly.
If we were all sitting
together, in like five minutes
I'd know what you all
did for a living, where
you lived, if you were dating
someone, if you had a child.
I might comment
on the cool shoes
that you're wearing,
whatever it may be.
Women bond very, very naturally
and very authentically.
So I really do think it's almost
re-imagining what networking is
and realizing that we're
building sort of relationships
with one another that are
real, that are authentic,
and that we know
will last awhile.
AUDIENCE: Folks, I'm sorry.
If you have a question, if
you can use the two mics,
just so that the sound
is picked up properly.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
obviously, it's true that--
I think we have it
right, and I think
we are aware of the
issues that women face,
that women aren't wrong for
doing the things that they do
and the way they present.
Being warm is never a bad thing.
Being kind is never a bad thing.
But I feel like we are in the
very vast minority of people
who are aware of this issue.
And obviously you
mentioned Hillary Clinton.
The vast majority of America
is not aware of the biases
that we are aware of.
So I guess, navigating
through this world,
I obviously am not condoning
that we should change
or anything.
But you did mention you
wanted to say sorry,
because you felt like
that was how you came off
as warm, warmer.
Because I grew up, people
calling me bossy all the time,
because I was confident, I
was able to say what I wanted.
Not being rude, but in
just a sense being direct.
But how do you avoid that?
Like what kind of strategies--
could you delve more
into like other things
you've tried as like a leader?
WENDY SACHS: Yeah.
Yeah, I do think that a lot
of it is facial expression.
So the problem when I was
told that I was abrasive,
I was actually working remotely.
So a lot of my conversations
were over the phone.
So I thought I was
being very direct.
And my boss actually said
to me, who is a woman,
she said, I know
that you're warm.
You smile, you're very
engaging in person.
But you know, on
the phone, people
think you're a little bossy.
And again, a man
would never have
been accused of being bossy.
I was just direct.
I thought, we've got time.
We've got 30 minutes on the
call, in, out, done, good.
They're not seeing me smile,
because it's on the phone.
But I do think so
that personal-- so
what I have learned is
I do try to smile a lot.
I mean, it's not
unnatural for me to smile.
I think I'm probably
now more aware of that.
And I also think,
maybe, that it also
comes with a little bit more
confidence in age, also.
Of just not feeling like
I have something to prove,
so maybe I'm not coming in
like, the bull in the china
store type of thing, that I'm
a little bit softer as I even
speak.
Yeah, I do.
I am hyper aware
of how I present.
And so my advice
to you is smile.
Smile, warmth, and then
say what you need to say.
Be smart, and never hedge on
being smart, as none of us
would do, I'm sure.
But you know, you
want to come across
and make your points clear.
There was something
else that I didn't
mention when I was talking.
And I think it's actually
really interesting.
And it goes to sort
of the solidarity
of the sisterhood, and this
networking, and the change
that I'm seeing.
And I write about, and it's
called the amplification
effect.
Have you all heard of this?
Yeah, yeah, right on.
So for those who
don't know, I had
read about this in
"The Washington Post"
that the women in
the Obama White House
realized very early
in the administration
that they were being ignored.
They were ignored
by the president,
and by pretty much
everyone in the West Wing.
And they'd come into meetings
and the president never
called on them for questions or
for their thoughts or anything
like that.
Or, if they did
speak up, their ideas
were being usurped by
the guy in the room.
You know?
So they made a point, and
all of a sudden, you know,
like, John is owning that point.
So they got together,
and they realized
that they needed to do
something about this,
and that they were going to
amplify each other's messages.
So if Yas said something
brilliant in a meeting
with the president,
as I'm sure she has,
I would then say, you
know, as Yas said earlier.
And now the point is
being owned by Yas.
I'm emphasizing that.
The president's looking
over at Yasmin like, oh,
yeah, smart lady, good point.
And they started doing that.
They started making sure that
they were calling on each other
and reinforcing the comments to
make sure that the guys weren't
stealing any of these ideas.
But something
interesting happened,
which was that President Obama
started calling on the women
more.
Started inviting them
to more meetings.
They were visible.
They made themselves visible.
So this whole concept
of amplifying each other
is really important.
And certainly not just in the
West Wing, but in the work
space, right?
We need to be
supporting each other.
We need to be recognizing
what we're saying,
what our contributions are.
And it's really,
really helpful to have
someone else do that for you.
I don't know if anyone here
read Jessica Bennett's book,
and I'm going to screw
up the name-- it's
"The Feminist Fight
Club" is her book,
and which is a great read.
And she writes about
having a boast bitch.
And that boast bitch
is someone who--
by the way, it could
be your best friend,
it could be your
mother, it could
be your sister-- it's having
someone be able to amplify
messages for you.
And I'm sure there's
tons of studies on,
with Facebook likes, and
Instagram likes, and you know,
what gets the most likes
and all this kind of stuff.
But there's something to be
said, when someone else says
something about you, or
someone posts something like,
oh, I'm so proud of my wife--
her book was published--
that tends to get more likes
than if I actually put out,
hey, my book was published.
So it's the same
sort of concept.
So you have someone else.
You have someone who's
amplifying the great work
that you're doing
in the workplace.
And having that boast
bitch is really effective.
First of all, I
just love the idea,
and I think it's very empowering
and very much as a sisterhood
that we need to be
supporting each other.
I know I digressed.
Does anyone have
any other questions?
I think we need to wrap it up.
Thank you all, thank you
guys for inviting me.
Thank you Google for having me.
This is quite an
honor to be here.
Truly, I'm thrilled to have
been able to speak at Google.
This is really very exciting.
Thank you.